there is a carnivore mood at the
campaign rally for ethiopia's ruling
prosperity party
supporters of prime minister habi ahmed
are keen to see him win a popular
mandate
they believe will enable him deal
decisively with the many challenges
facing the country
the elections should have taken place
earlier this year but were twice
postponed
due to the outbreak of covet 19 and
logistical challenges faced by the
electoral body
a total of that seven million people
have registered to vote
ergaw burana a farmer in the populace
oram origin
is one of them we have registered and
received
education and guidance on how to vote
however we are uncertain what election
will bring us we are really hoping for
peace and a better ethiopia
the prime minister's prosperity party
upon the ethiopian movement has fielded
the most candidates for national
parliamentary races
and is widely expected to secure a new
term
he however faces opposition from 47
parties
most of whom are seeking more
sovereignty for the regions they
represent
ethiopia africa's second most populous
nation with some 115 million people
has a federal system and 10 regional
governments
many of whom have border disputes or are
experiencing
unrest the the ruling party is extremely
ready
to exercise democracy the government is
extremely ready and has officially
promised to the public
to at least exercise democracy in this
country and and the public is very much
eager
to exercise democracy even though these
opportunities are there
the challenges are also very very clear
because ethiopia is an extremely
polarized political system for a very
long time
known for dictatorial regimes
very modern and civilized democratic
exercises are
scarce in this country as a result when
election comes
people fear of post-election violences
even in the best of times organizing
smooth elections is a tall order
in ethiopia a vast country hobbled
by poor infrastructure diplomats
following the process say the electoral
board is missing logistical support
usually provided by the military which
is preoccupied in the seven month long
war
in tigray it has been accused of
committing widespread human rights
abuses in the region
opposition parties maintain the
elections are not on track to meet
international standards
for freedom fairness and transparency
already several have announced plans to
abstain from the election
yet some are choosing to stay in the
race hoping their participation
will help the country in its quest to
democratize
yes we are very hopeful and
as we said internally as we say it
internally we
are giving the ruling party a run for
their money
and will continue doing that until the
election campaigns
in this next week and we are hopeful
that the next parliament will not be as
dull as
the previous ones the government's
detention of thousands of opposition
leaders and supporters
some of whom have been deprived of due
process
tortured or even summarily executed
is also fueling the electorate sphere
according to amnesty international
and as ethiopia hobbles towards election
day many here hope
the polls will be free and fair muhammad
al-jazeera ethiopia